quelques détonations en pleine campagne
la guerre est déclarée contre le frelon
asiatique
c'est avec une arme habituellement
utilisé pour jouer au paintball que ceux
professionnels tentent de détruire un
nid de frelons asiatiques
une nouvelle technique testée depuis
deux ans les billets - est envoyé dans
le nid et vont diffuser un insecticide
qui va pouvoir tuer le le niveau maximum
de joueurs grâce à la série site qui va
se diffuser dans le nil et par contact
les insectes vont toucher ce produit et
se contaminer les uns les uns les autres
jeunes y sera mort au bout de deux jours
maximum
le frelon asiatique est plus petit que
le frelon traditionnel mais bien plus
dangereux le prédateur m décapiter les
abeilles et manger leur thorax empli de
protéines responsables de la disparition
de nombreuses colonies
ce frelon serait arrivé de chine dans un
convoi de poterie il y a dix ans depuis
il a colonisé une grande partie du pays
les habitants fabrique des pièges maison
le cocktail alors se compose de sirop de
grenadine sirop de cassis du vin blanc
et du panache et on va 10 centilitres de
vin blanc disserter de panache et
environs quoi donc l'intérêt c'est que
ça pièges à frelons asiatiques pour les
apiculteurs et les élus les pièges mis
en place par les habitants sont
insuffisants une intervention
professionnelle coûte entre 50 et 150
euros mais le coût de la destruction des
nids de frelons asiatiques en pleine
saison est bien trop élevé pour les
petites communes
si rien n'est fait les apiculteurs sont
appelés à disparaître dans les cinq
premières prochaines années surtout les
amateurs mais les amateurs c'est 50 % du
cheptel national
les professionnels demandent à ce que le
frelon asiatique soit classé comme
espèce nuisible afin de mettre en place
un plan de lutte efficace